- Welcome to the Huberman Lab Podcast,
where we discuss science
and science-based tools
for everyday life.
[lively music]
I'm Andrew Huberman,
and I'm a professor of
neurobiology and ophthalmology
at Stanford School of Medicine.
Today, my guest is Dr. Erich Jarvis.
Dr. Jarvis is a professor at
the Rockefeller University
in New York City
and his laboratory studies,
the neurobiology of
vocal learning, language,
speech disorders,
and remarkably, the
relationship between language,
music and movement, in particular dance.
His work spans from genomics,
so the very genes that make up our genome
and the genomes of other species
that speak and have language
such as songbirds and parrots
all the way up to neural circuits,
that is the connections
in the brain and body
that govern our ability to learn
and generate specific sounds
and movements coordinated
with those sounds,
including hand movements
and all the way up to cognition,
that is our ability to
think in specific ways,
based on what we are saying
and the way that we comprehend
what other people are
saying, singing and doing.
As you'll soon see,
I was immediately transfixed
and absolutely enchanted
by Dr. Jarvis's description
of his work and the ways that it impacts
all the various aspects of our lives.
For instance, I learned from
Dr. Jarvis that as we read,
we are generating very low-levels
of motor activity in our throat.
That is, we are speaking the
words that we are reading
at a level below the perception of sound
or our own perception of those words.
But if one were to put an amplifier
or to measure the firing of those muscles
in our vocal chords,
we'd find that as we're
reading information,
we are actually speaking that information.
And as I learned, and you'll soon learn,
there's a direct link
between those species
in the world that have song and movement,
which many of us would
associate with dance
and our ability to learn and
generate complex language.
So for people with speech
disorders like stutter,
or for people who are interested
in multiple language learning,
bilingual, trilingual, et cetera,
and frankly for anyone who is interested
in how we communicate through
words, written or spoken,
I'm certain today's episode is going to be
an especially interesting
and important one for you.
Dr. Jarvis's work is so pioneering
that he has been awarded
truly countless awards.
I'm not going to take our time to list off
all the various important
awards that he's received,
but I should point out
that in addition to being
a decorated professor
at the Rockefeller University,
he is also an investigator
with the Howard Hughes Medical Institute,
the so-called HHMI.
And for those of you that don't know,
HHMI investigators are selected
on an extremely competitive basis
that they have to re-up,
that is they have to
recompete every five years.
They actually receive a
grade every five years
that dictates whether or
not they are no longer
a Howard Hughes investigator
or whether or not they can
advance to another five years
of funding for their important research.
And indeed, Howard Hughes investigators
are selected not just for
the rigor of their work,
but for their pioneering spirit
and their ability to take on
high-risk, high-benefit work,
which is exactly the kind of work
that Dr. Jarvis has been
providing for decades now.
Again, I think today's episode
is one of the more unique
and special episodes that we've had
on the Huberman Lab Podcast.
I single it out because it really spans
from the basic to the applied
and Dr. Jarvis's story is
an especially unique one
in terms of how he arrived
at becoming a neurobiologist.
So for those of you that are interested
in personal journey and personal story,
Dr. Jarvis's is truly a
special and important one.
I'm pleased to announce that
the Huberman Lab Podcast
is now partnered with
Momentous supplements.
We partnered with Momentous
for several important reasons.
First of all, they ship internationally
because we know that many of you
are located outside of the United States.
Second of all, and perhaps most important,
the quality of their
supplements is second to none,
both in terms of purity and precision
of the amounts of the ingredients.
Third, we've really emphasized supplements
that are single ingredient supplements,
and that are supplied in
dosages that allow you
to build a supplementation protocol
that's optimized for cost,
that's optimized for effectiveness,
and that you can add
things and remove things
from your protocol in a way
that's really systematic and scientific.
If you'd like to see the supplements
that we partner with Momentous on,
you can go to livemomentous.com/huberman.
There, you'll see those supplements.
And just keep in mind
that we are constantly expanding
the library of supplements
available through Momentous
on a regular basis.
Again, that's livemomentous.com/huberman.
Before we begin, I'd like to
emphasize that this podcast
is separate from my teaching
and research roles at Stanford.
It is however, part of
my desire and effort
to bring zero cost to consumer
information about science
and science-related tools
to the general public.
In keeping with that theme,
I'd like to thank the
sponsors of today's podcast.
Our first sponsor is InsideTracker.
InsideTracker is a
personalized nutrition platform
that analyzes data from your blood and DNA
to help you better meet your immediate
and long-term health goals.
I've long been a believer in
getting regular blood work done
for the simple reason
that many of the factors
that impact your immediate
and long-term health
can only be analyzed from
a quality blood test.
And nowadays with the
advent of modern DNA test,
you can also get insight
into, for example,
what your biological age is
and compare that to
your chronological age.
The problem with a lot of DNA tests
and blood tests, however,
is you get information back
about metabolic factors, lipids,
and hormones, and so forth,
but you don't know what to do
with or about that information.
InsideTracker solves that
problem with a simple platform
that allows you to click
on any specific factor,
learn more about it and what
it does in your brain and body,
and also the various
nutritional supplementation
and other types of
interventions you can take
to bring the levels of that factor
into the ranges that are
optimal for you and your health.
If you'd like to try InsideTracker,
you can go to insidetracker.com/huberman
to get 20% off any of
InsideTracker's plans.
That's insidetracker.com/huberman
to get 20% off.
Today's episode is also
brought to us by ROKA.
ROKA makes eyeglasses and sunglasses
that are of the absolute highest quality.
They also have some really unique features
that make them especially attractive
from the standpoint of
aesthetics and performance.
The company was founded by two
all-American swimmers from Stanford
and everything about their
eyeglasses and sunglasses
were designed with performance in mind.
Initially, the eyeglasses and sunglasses
were designed for sport,
that is for running and
for cycling, et cetera.
And indeed, still their eyeglasses
and sunglasses are very lightweight
and they won't slip off
your face if you get sweaty,
but they also have a terrific aesthetic.
You can wear them to work.
You can wear them out to eat.
I wear readers at night
when I work, or if I drive
and I wear sunglasses sometimes
during the middle of the day,
if it's too bright and I need
sunglasses in order to see.
If you'd like to try ROKA
eyeglasses, or sunglasses,
you can go to ROKA, that's ROKA.com
and enter the code huberman
to save 20% off your first order.
Again, that's ROKA.com
and enter the code huberman at checkout.
Today's episode is also
brought to us by LMNT.
LMNT is an electrolyte drink
that has everything you
need and nothing you don't,
meaning no sugar, but
plenty of the correct ratios
of sodium, magnesium and potassium,
and those three electrolytes,
sodium, magnesium, and potassium
are critical for your neuron,
your nerve cell function,
and for the function of all the cells
in your brain and body.
I've mentioned this before on the podcast,
but I'm a fan of salt,
not taking too much salt,
but certainly not getting too little salt.
LMNT has 1000 milligrams,
that is one gram of salt,
which might sound like a lot of salt.
But for many people,
especially people who are
following low carbohydrate diets,
or who are exercising or
sweating a lot, or both,
that level of salt can actually help you
in many circumstances.
Getting the appropriate level of salt,
and certainly the appropriate
levels of electrolytes
will improve your cognitive function
and will improve your
physical performance.
If you'd like to try LMNT
you can go to drinklmnt,
that's lmnt.com/huberman,
and you'll get a free
sample pack with your order.
That's drinklmnt.com/huberman.
And now, for my discussion
with Dr. Erich Jarvis.
Erich, it's so great to have you here.
- Thank you.
- Yeah.
Very interested in learning from you
about speech and language.
And even as I ask the question,
I realize that a lot of
people, including myself,
probably don't fully
appreciate the distinction
between speech and language, right?
Speech, I think of as the motor patterns,
the production of sound
that has meaning, hopefully.
And language, of course,
comes in various languages
and varieties of ways of communicating.
But in terms of the study
of speech and language,
and thinking about how the brain
organizes speech and language,
what are the similarities?
What are the differences?
How should we think about
speech and language?
- Yeah, well, I'm glad you,
you know, inviting me here.
And I'm also glad to
get that first question,
which I consider a provocative one.
The reason why, I've been struggling,
what is the difference
with speech and language
for many years.
And realize, why am I struggling,
is because there are behavioral terms,
let's call 'em psychologically,
psychology developed kind of terms
that don't actually align
exactly with brain function.
All right.
And the question is there a distinction
between speech and language?
And when I look at the brain
of work that other people
have done, work we have done,
also compared it with animal models,
like those who can imitate sounds
like parrots and songbirds.
I start to see there really
isn't such a sharp distinction.
So, to get at what I think is going on,
let me tell you how some
people think of it now.
That there's a separate
language module in the brain
that has all the
algorithms and computations
that influence the speech pathway
on how to produce sound
and the auditory pathway
on how to perceive
and interpret it for speech
or for, you know, sound
that we call speech.
And it turns out,
I don't think there is any good evidence
for a separate language module.
Instead, there is a
speech production pathway
that's controlling our larynx,
controlling our jaw muscles
that has built within it
all the complex algorithms
for spoken language.
And there's the auditory pathway
that has built within it,
all the complex algorithms
for understanding speech,
not separate from a language module.
And this speech production pathway
is specialized to humans
and parrots and songbirds,
whereas this auditory perception pathway
is more ubiquitous amongst
the animal kingdom.
And this is why dogs can understand,
"sit", "sientese", "come here, boy",
"get the ball" and so forth.
Dogs can understand several
hundred human speech words.
Great apes, you can teach
them for several thousand,
but they can't say a word.
- Fascinating.
Because you've raised a
number of animal species
early on here and because I have a,
basically an obsession with animals
since the time I was very small,
I have to ask, which
animals have language?
Which animals have modes of communication
that are sort of like language.
- [Erich] Yeah.
- You know, I've heard whale songs.
I don't know what they're saying.
They sound very beautiful,
but they could be insulting
each other for all I know.
- [Erich] Yeah.
- And they very well may be.
Dolphins, birds, I mean,
what do we understand about
modes of communication
that are like language,
but might not be what would
classically be called language?
- Yes, right.
So, modes of communication
that people would define as language,
more, very, in a very narrow definition,
they would say, production
of sound, so speech.
But what about the hands,
the gesturing with the hands?
What about a bird who is doing
aerial displays in the air,
communicating information
through body language, right.
Well, I'm going to go back to the brain.
So what I think is going on
is for spoken language,
we're using the speech pathway
and all the complex algorithms there.
Next to the brain regions
that are controlling spoken language
are the brain regions for
gesturing with the hands.
And that hand parallel pathway
has also complex algorithms
that we can utilize.
And some species are more
advanced in these circuits,
whether it's sound or gesturing with hands
and some are less advanced.
Now, we, humans and a few others
are the most advanced
for the speech sounds
or the spoken language,
but a non-human primate
can produce gesturing
in a more advanced form than
they could produce sound.
I'm not sure I got that across clearly,
just to say that humans
are the most advanced
at spoken language,
but not necessarily as big a
difference at gestural language
compared to some of the species.
- Very clear and very interesting.
And immediately prompts the question,
have there been brain imaging
or other sorts of studies
evaluating neural activity
in the context of, you know,
cultures and languages,
at least that I associate
with a lot of hand movement,
like Italian.
- Yep.
- Versus, I don't know,
maybe you could give us
some examples of cultures
where language is not associated with
as much overt hand movement.
- Yes, so as you and I
are talking here today
and people who are
listening, but can't see us,
we're actually gesturing
with our hands as we talk
without knowing it or
doing it unconsciously.
And if we were talking on a telephone,
I would have one hand here
and I'd be gesturing with the other hand.
[Andrew laughs]
Without even you seeing me, right?
And so why is that?
Some have argued and I would agree,
but based upon what we've seen
is that there's an
evolutionary relationship
between the brain pathways
that control speech
production and gesturing.
And the brain regions I mentioned
are directly adjacent to each other.
And why is that?
I think that the brain
pathways that control speech
evolved out of the brain pathways
that control body movement.
All right.
And that
when you talk about Italian, French,
English, and so forth,
each one of those languages
come with a learned set of gestures
that you can communicate with.
Now, how is that related to other animals?
Well, Cocoa, a gorilla who is raised
with humans for 39 years or more,
learned how to do gesture communication,
learned how to sign
language, so to speak, right?
But Cocoa couldn't produce those sounds.
Cocoa could understand them as well
by seeing somebody sign
or hearing somebody produce speech,
but Cocoa couldn't
produce it with her voice.
And so, what's going on there is that
a number of species, not all of them,
a number of species have
motor pathways in the brain
where you can do learn gesturing,
rudimentary language, if you
wanted, say with your limbs,
even if it's not as advanced as humans.
But they don't have this extra
brain pathway for the sound.
So they can't gesture with their voice
in the way that they
gesture with their hands.
- I see.
One thing that I've wondered
about for a very long time
is whether or not
primitive emotions and primitive sounds
are the early substrate of language.
And whether or not there's a bridge
that we can draw between those
in terms of just the
basic respiration systems
associated with different
extreme feelings.
Here's the way I'm
imagining this might work.
When I smell something delicious,
I typically inhale more.
- Hmm hmm.
- And I might say, mmm,
or something like that.
Whereas if I smell something putrid,
I typically turn away, and I wince
and I will exhale [exhales],
you know or sort of
kind of like turn away,
trying to not ingest those molecules
or inhale those molecules.
I could imagine that these
are the basic dark and light contrasts
of the language system.
And as I say that,
I'm saying that from the
orientation of a vision scientist
who thinks of all visual images built up
in a very basic way of
a hierarchical map model
of the ability to see dark and light.
So I could imagine this kind of primitive
to more sophisticated pyramid
of sound to language.
Is this a crazy idea?
Do we have any evidence
this is the way it works?
- No, it's not a crazy idea.
And in fact,
you hit upon one of the key distinctions
in the field of research
that I started out in,
which is vocal learning research.
So for vocal communication,
you have most vertebrate species vocalize,
but most of them are
producing innate sounds
that they're born with producing,
that is babies crying, for example,
or dogs barking.
And only a few species have
learned vocal communication,
the ability to imitate sounds.
And that is what makes
spoken language special.
When people think of what's
special about language,
it's the learned vocalizations.
That is what's rare.
And so, this distinction
between innateness and learned
is more of a bigger dichotomy
when it comes to vocalizations
than for other behaviors
in the animal kingdom.
And when you go in the brain,
you see it there as well.
And so all the things you talked about,
the breathing, the grunting and so forth,
a lot of that is handled
by the brain stem circuits,
you know, right around the
level of your neck and below.
Like a reflex kind of thing.
So, or even some emotional
aspects of your behavior
in the hypothalamus and so forth.
But for a learned behavior,
learning how to speak,
learning how to play the piano,
teaching a dog to learn how to do tricks
is using the forebrain circuits.
And what has happened is
that there's a lot of forebrain circuits
that are controlling,
learning how to move body
parts in these species,
but not for the vocalizations.
But in humans and in parrots
and in some other species,
somehow, we acquired circuits
where the forebrain has
taken over the brain stem
and now using that brain stem,
not only to produce the innate
behaviors or vocal behaviors,
but the learned ones as well.
- Do we have any sense
of when modern or
sophisticated language evolved?
You know, thinking back to the
species that we evolved from,
and even within Homo sapiens,
has there been an evolution of language?
Has there been a devolution
of language? [laughs]
- Yeah.
Yeah, I would say,
and to be able to answer that question,
it does come with the caveat
that I think we humans overrate ourselves
compared to other species.
And so it makes even scientists go astray
in trying to hypothesize
when, you especially
don't find fossil evidence
of language that easily
out there in terms of
what happened in the past.
Amongst the primates,
which we humans belong to,
we are the only ones that
have this advanced vocal learning ability.
Now, it was assumed that
it was only Homo sapiens,
then you can go back in time now
based upon genomic data,
not only of us living humans,
but of the fossils that have been found
for Homo sapiens, of Neanderthals,
of Denisovan individuals
and discover that our
ancestor, our human ancestors,
supposedly hybridized with
these other hominid species.
And it was assumed that
these other hominid species
don't learn how to imitate sounds.
I don't know of any species today
that's a vocal learner
that can have children
with a non-vocal learning species.
I don't see it.
Doesn't mean it didn't exist.
And when we look at the genetic data
from these ancestral
hominids, that, you know,
where we can look at
genes that are involved
in learned vocal communication,
they have the same
sequence as we humans do
for genes that function
in speech circuits.
So I think Neanderthals
had spoken language.
I'm not going to say it's as
advanced as what it is in humans.
I don't know.
But I think it's been there for at least
between 500,000 to a million years
that our ancestors had this ability
and that we've been coming
more and more advanced with it
culturally and possibly genetically.
But I think it's evolved sometime
in the last 500,000 to a million years.
- Incredible.
Maybe we could talk a little bit more
about the overlap between brain circuits
that control language and speech
in humans and other animals.
I was weaned in the neuroscience era
where birdsong and the ability of birds
to learn their tooter song
was and still is a prominent field,
subfield of neuroscience.
And then of course,
neuroimaging of humans speaking
and learning, et cetera,
and this notion of a critical period,
a time in which language
is learned more easily
than it is later in life.
And the names of the different brain areas
were quite different.
If one opens the textbooks,
we hear Wernicke's and
Broca's for the humans.
And you look at the birds of it,
I remember, you know.
- HVC.
- Robustus, striatum.
Area X.
- That's right.
That's right, yes.
- Et cetera.
But for most of our listeners,
those names won't mean a whole lot,
but in terms of homologies
between areas in terms of
function, what do we know?
And how similar or different
are the brain areas
controlling speech and language
in say a songbird and a young human child?
- Yeah, so, going back to the 1950s
or even a little earlier,
and Peter Muller and others who
got involved in neurotology,
the study of neurobiology of behavior
in a natural way, right.
You know, they start to
find that behaviorally,
there are these species of birds
like songbirds and parrots,
and now we also know
hummingbirds, just three of them
out of the 40-something bird
groups out there on the planet,
orders, that they can
imitate sounds like we do.
And so that was a similarity.
In other words, they had
this kind of behavior
that's more similar to us
than chimpanzees have with us
or than chickens have with them, right,
their closer relatives.
And then they discovered
even more similarities,
these critical periods
that if you remove a child,
you know, this unfortunately
happens where a child is feral
and is not raised with human
and goes through their
puberty phase of growth,
it becomes hard for them to
learn a language as an adult.
So there's this critical
period where you learn best.
And even later on, when
you're in regular society,
it's hard to learn.
Well, the birds undergo these same thing.
And then it was discovered
that if they become deaf,
we humans become deaf,
our speech starts to deteriorate
without any kind of therapy.
If a non-human primate or, you know,
or let's say a chicken becomes deaf,
their vocalizations don't deteriorate.
very little at least.
Well, this happens in
the vocal learning birds.
So there were all these
behavioral parallels
that came along with a package,
and then people looked into the brain.
Fernando Nottebohm, my former PhD advisor,
and began to discover the
Area X you talked about,
the robust nucleus of the archipallium.
And these brain pathways were not found
in the species who couldn't imitate
so there was a parallel here.
And then jumping many
years later, you know,
I started to dig down
into these brain circuits
to discover that these brain circuits
had parallel functions with
the brain circuits for humans,
even though they're by a different name,
like Broca's laryngeal motor cortex.
And most recently,
we discovered not only
the actual circuitry
and the connectivity are similar,
but the underlying
genes that are expressed
in these brain regions
in a specialized way,
different from the rest of the brain,
are also similar between humans,
and songbirds and parrots.
So all the way down to the genes.
And now we're finding
the specific mutations
are also similar, not always
identical, but similar,
which indicates remarkable convergence
for a so-called complex behavior
in species separated by 300 million years
from a common ancestor.
And not only that,
we are discovering that
mutations in these genes
that cause speech deficits
in humans, like in FOXP2,
if you put those same mutations
or similar type of deficits
in these vocal learning birds,
you get similar deficits.
So convergence of the behavior
is associated with
similar genetic disorders
of the behavior.
- Incredible.
I have to ask, do hummingbird
sing, or do they hum?
- Hummingbirds hum with their wings
and sing with their syrinx.
- In a coordinated way?
- In a coordinated way.
There's some species of
hummingbirds that actually will,
Doug Ashler showed this,
that will flap their wings
and create a slapping
sound with their wings
that's in unison with their song
and you would not know it,
but it sounds like a particular
syllable in their songs,
even though it's their wings
and their voice at the same time.
- Hummingbirds are clapping to their song?
- Clapping with their,
they're snapping their wings together
in unison with a song to make it like,
if I'm going ba, da, da,
da [bangs], but, da [bangs]
and I banged on the table
except they make it almost
sound like their voice
with their wings.
- Incredible.
- Yes.
- I, I'm...
- And they got some of the
smallest brains around.
- As the kids would say mind blown, right?
- Yes. Yes.
- Incredible.
- Yes.
- Incredible, I love hummingbirds.
And I always feel like
it's such a special thing
to get a moment to see one
because they move around so fast
and they fled away so fast in
these ballistic trajectories.
- [Erich] Yep.
- That when you get to see
one stationary for a moment,
or even just hovering there,
you feel like you're extracting so much
from their little microcosm of life,
but now I realize they're
playing music essentially.
- Right, exactly.
And what's amazing about hummingbirds
and I'm going to say, vocal
learning species in general,
is that for whatever reason,
they seem to evolve
multiple complex traits.
You know, this idea that
the evolving language,
spoken language in particular,
comes along with a set of specializations.
- Incredible.
- Yeah.
- When I was coming up in neuroscience,
I learned that I think it
was the work of Peter Muller
that young birds learn,
songbirds learned their tooter
song and learn it quite well,
but that they could learn
the song of another tooter.
In other words, they
could learn a different,
and for the listeners,
I'm doing air quotes here,
"a different language",
"a different bird song",
different than their own species song.
But never as well as they could learn
their own natural genetically linked song.
- Yes.
- Genetically linked,
meaning that it would be like
me being raised in a different culture,
and that I would learn the other language,
but not as well as I would
have learned English.
This is the idea.
- Yes.
- Is that true?
- That is true, yes.
And that's what I learned
growing up as well.
And talked to Peter Muller
himself about before he passed.
Yeah, he used to call it the
innate predisposition to learn.
All right.
So which would be kind of the equivalent
in the linguistic community
of universal grammar.
There is something genetically
influencing our vocal communication
on top of what we learned culturally.
And so there's this balance
between the genetic control of speech
or a song in these birds
and the learned cultural control.
And so, yes, if you were to take,
you know, I mean, in this case,
we actually tried this
at Rockefeller later on.
Take a zebra finch and
raise it with a canary,
it would sing a song
that was sort of like a hybrid in between.
We call it a can-inch, right?
[both laughing]
And vice versa for the canary,
because there's something different
about their vocal musculature
or the circuitry in the brain.
And with a zebra finch, even
with a closely related species,
if you would take a zebra
finch, a young animal,
and in one cage next to
it placed its own species,
adult male, right.
And in the other cage placed
a Bengalese finch next to it,
it would preferably learn the song
from its own species neighbor.
But if you remove its neighbor,
it would learn that
Bengalese finch very well.
- [Andrew] Fantastic.
- It has something to do
with also the social bonding
with your own species.
- Incredible.
That raises a question that I,
based on something I also heard,
but I don't have any scientific
peer-reviewed publication to point to,
which is this idea of Pidgin not the bird,
but this idea of when multiple cultures
and languages converge in
a given geographic area,
that the children of all the
different native languages
will come up with their own language.
I think this was in island culture,
maybe in Hawaii, called Pidgin,
which is sort of a hybrid
of the various languages
that their parents speak at home
and that they themselves speak.
And that somehow Pidgin
again, not the bird,
but a language called Pidgin,
for reasons, I don't know,
harbors certain basic
elements of all language.
Is that true?
Is that not true?
- I would say, I haven't
studied enough myself
in terms of Pidgin, specifically,
but in terms of cultural
evolution of language
and hybridization between
different cultures and so forth,
even amongst birds with different dialects
and you bring them together, you know,
what is going on here
is cultural evolution
remarkably tracks genetic evolution.
So if you bring people
from two separate populations together
that have been in their
separate populations,
evolutionarily, at least
for hundreds of generations,
so someone's speaking Chinese,
someone's speaking English,
and that child is then
learning from both of them.
Yes, that child's going
to be able to pick up
and merge phonemes and words together
in a way that an adult
wouldn't, because, why?
They're experiencing both
languages at the same time
during their critical period years,
in a way that adults would
not be able to experience.
And so you get a hybrid.
And the lowest common denominator
is going to be what they share.
And so the phonemes
that they've re retained
in each of their languages
is what's going to be,
I imagine, used the most.
- Interesting.
So we've got brain circuits
in songbirds and in humans
that in many ways are similar,
perhaps not in their exact wiring,
but in their basic contour of wiring.
And genes that are expressed
in both sets of neural circuits
in very distinct species
that are responsible for these phenomenon
we're calling speech and language.
What sorts of things are
those genes controlling?
I could imagine they were
controlling the wiring
of connections between brain areas.
You know, essentially a map
of, you know, of a circuit,
basically like an engineer
would design a circuit
for speech and language,
nature designed the circuit
but presumably other things too.
Like the ability to connect motor patterns
within the throat of
muscles within the throat,
or in the control of the tongue.
I mean, what are these genes doing?
- You're pretty good, yeah.
You've made some very good
guesses there that makes sense.
So, yes, one of the things that differ
in the speech pathways of us
and these song pathways of birds
is some of the connections
are fundamentally different
than the surrounding circuits,
like a direct cortical connection
from the areas that control
vocalizations in the cortex
or the motor neurons
that control the larynx,
in humans or the syrinx in birds.
And so we actually made a prediction
that since some of these
connections differ,
we're going to find genes that
control neural connectivity,
and that specialize in
that function, that differ.
And that's exactly what we found.
Genes that control what
we call axon guidance
and form neuronal connections,
and what was interesting,
it was sort of in the opposite
direction that we expected.
That is, some of these genes,
actually, a number of them
that control neural
connectivity were turned off
in the speech circuit, all right.
And it didn't make sense to us at first
until we started to realize the function
of these genes are to repel
connections from forming,
so repulsive molecules.
And so when you turn them off,
they allow certain connections to form
that normally would have not formed.
So by turning it off,
you gain a function for speech, right?
Other genes that surprised us
were genes involved in calcium
buffering neuroprotection,
like Parvalbumin or heat-shock proteins,
so when your brain gets
hot, these proteins turn on.
And we couldn't figure
out for a long time,
why is that the case?
And then the idea popped
to me one day and said, ah,
when I heard the larynx is
the fastest firing muscles
in the body, all right.
In order to vibrate sound
and modulate sound in the way we do,
you have to control,
you have to move those muscles, you know,
three to four to five times faster
than just regular walking or running.
And so when you stick electrodes
in the brain areas that
control learned vocalizations
in these birds and I
think in humans as well,
those neurons are firing at a higher rate
to control these muscles.
And so what is that going to do?
You're going to have lots of
toxicity in those neurons,
unless you upregulate molecules
that take out the extra load
that is needed to control the larynx.
And then finally, a third set of genes
that are specialized
in these speech circuit
are involved in neuroplasticity.
Neuroplasticity, meaning
allowing the brain circuits
to be more flexible so
you can learn better.
And why is that?
I think learning how to produce speech
is a more complex learning ability
than say learning how to walk
or learning how to do tricks
and jumps and so forth that dogs do.
- Yeah, it's interesting as you say that,
because I realize that
many aspects of speech
are sort of reflexive.
I'm not thinking about
each word I'm going to say,
they just sort of roll out of my mouth,
hopefully with some forethought.
We both know people that
seem to speak, think less,
fewer synapses between
their brain and their mouth
than others, right.
- Yes.
- A lot of examples out there,
and some people are very
deliberate in their speech,
but nonetheless, that much
of speech has to be precise.
And some of it less precise.
In terms of plasticity of speech
and the ability to learn
multiple languages,
but even just one language,
what's going on in the critical period,
the so-called critical period?
- Yeah.
- Why is it that, so my
niece speaks Spanish.
She's Guatemalan and speaks Spanish
and English incredibly well.
She's 14-years-old.
I've struggled with Spanish my whole life.
My father is bilingual.
My mother is not.
I've tried to learn Spanish as an adult.
It's really challenging.
I'm told that had I learned
it when I was eight,
I would be better off.
- That's right.
- Or it would be installed within me.
So the first question is,
is it easier to learn multiple languages
without an accent early in life?
And if so, why?
And then the second question is
if one can already speak
more than one language
as a consequence of childhood learning,
is it easier to acquire
new languages later on?
- So, the answer to both of
those questions is yes, in that,
but to explain this, I
need to let you know,
actually the entire brain
is undergoing a critical
period development,
not just the speech pathways.
And so it's easier to
learn how to play a piano.
It's easier to learn how to ride a bike
for the first time and so forth
as a young child than it is later in life.
What I mean easier in
terms of when you start
from first principles
of learning something.
So the very first time,
if you're going to
learn Chinese as a child
versus the very first time
you learn Chinese as an adult
or learning to play piano
as a child versus an adult.
But the speech pathways,
or let's say speech behavior,
I think has a stronger critical period
change to it than other circuits.
And why, what's going on there in general?
Why do you need a critical period
to make you more stable,
to make you more stubborn, so to speak?
The reason I believe is
that the brain is not for,
the brain can only hold
so much information.
And if you are undergoing
rapid learning to learn,
to acquire new knowledge,
you also have to, you know, dumb stuff.
Put in memory or information in the trash,
like in a computer.
You only have so many gigabases of memory.
And so therefore, plus also for survival,
you don't want to keep forgetting things.
And so the brain is designed, I believe,
to undergo this critical period
and solidify the circuits with
what you learned as a child
and you use that for
the rest of your life.
And we humans stay even more
plastic in our brain functions
controlled by a gene called srGAP2.
We have an extra copy of it
that leads our speech circuit
and other brain regions
in a more immature state throughout life
compared to other animals.
So we're more immature.
We're still juvenile like
compared to other animals.
- I knew it.
- But we still go through
the critical periods
like they all do.
And now the question you asked about,
if you learn more languages as a child,
is it easier to learn as an adult?
And that's a common finding
out there in the literature.
There's some that argue against it.
But for those that support
it, the idea there is,
you are born with a set of innate sounds
you can produce of phonemes.
And you narrow that down
because not all languages use all of them.
And so you narrow down the ones
you use to string the phonemes together,
in words that you learn
and you maintain those
phonemes as an adult.
And here comes along another language
that's using those phonemes
or in different combinations
you're not used to.
And therefore, it's like
starting from first principles,
but if you already have them
in multiple languages that you're using,
then it makes it easier to use them
in another third or fourth language.
- I see, incredible.
- So, it's not like your brain
has maintained greater plasticity,
it's your brain has
maintained greater ability
to produce different sounds
that then allows you to learn
another language faster.
- Got it.
Are the hand gestures
associated with sounds
or with meanings of words?
- I think the hand gestures are associated
with both the sounds and the meaning.
When I say sound like if
you are really angry, right,
and you are making a loud
screaming noise, right,
you may make hand gestures
that look like you're going
to beat the wall, right?
Because you're making loud
sounds and loud gestures, right.
But if you want to explain
something like, come over here,
what I just do now to you
for those who can't see me,
I swung my hand towards you
and swung it here to me.
That has a meaning to it, to come here.
So just like with the voice,
the hand gestures are
producing both, you know,
both qualities of sound.
- And for people that
speak multiple languages,
especially those that learn
those multiple languages
early in development,
do they switch their
patterns of motor movements
according to let's say,
going from Italian to Arabic
or from Arabic to French
in a way that matches
the precision of language
that they're speaking?
- You know what?
You just asked me a question,
I don't know the answer to.
I would imagine that would
make sense because of switching
in terms of sometimes people
might call this code switching,
even different dialects
of the same language.
Could you do that with your gestures?
I imagine so, but I really don't
know if that's true or not.
- Okay, well, I certainly don't
know from my own experience
because I only speak one language.
[both laughing]
Before we continue with
today's discussion,
I'd like to just briefly
acknowledge our sponsor,
Athletic Greens, now called AG1.
Athletic Greens, aka AGI,
is an all-in-one vitamin
mineral probiotic drink
that also has adaptogens
and digestive enzymes.
I've been taking Athletic
Greens since way back in 2012
so I'm delighted that they're
sponsoring the podcast.
The reason I started
taking Athletic Greens
and the reason I still drink
Athletic Greens twice a day
is that it supplies
total foundational coverage
of my vitamin mineral needs
and it supplies important
nutrients that I need
to support my gut microbiome.
The gut microbiome, as many of you know,
supports the immune system
and it also supports the
so-called gut brain access,
which is vital for
mood, for energy levels,
for regulating focus
and many other features
of our mental health
and physical health that
impact our daily performance
and high performance in any endeavors
we might be involved in.
If you'd like to try Athletic Greens,
you can go to athleticgreens.com/huberman
and claim a special offer.
They're giving away
five free travel packs,
plus a year's supply of
vitamin D3 K2 with every order.
And of course, vitamin D3 K2
are vital for all sorts of
things like hormone health
and metabolic health
and K2 for cardiovascular
health and calcium regulation.
Again, you can go to
athleticgreens.com/huberman
to claim that special offer.
To go a little bit into the
abstract, but not too far,
what about modes of speech and language
that seem to have a depth
of emotionality and meaning,
but for which it departs
from structured language.
Here's what I mean, poetry.
- Hmm hmm.
- I think of musicians,
like there's some Bob
Dylan songs that, to me,
I understand the individual words.
I like to think there's an
emotion associated with it.
at least, I experience
some sort of emotion
and I have a guess about
what he was experiencing.
But if I were to just read
it linearly without the music
and without him singing it, or
somebody singing it like him,
it wouldn't hold any meaning.
So in other words, words
that seem to have meaning,
but not associated with language,
but somehow tap into an emotionality.
- Yep, absolutely.
So, we call this difference
semantic communication,
communication with meaning
and effective communication,
communication that has more
of an emotional feeling content to it,
you know, but not with,
you know, the semantics.
And the two can be mixed up,
like with singing words that have meaning,
but also have this effect of emotional,
you just love the sound of the
singer that you're hearing.
And initially, you know,
psychologists, scientists, in general,
thought that these were
going to be controlled
by different brain circuits.
And it is the case.
There are emotional brain
centers in the hypothalamus,
in the cingulate cortex and so forth,
that do give tone to the sounds.
But I believe, you know,
based upon imaging work
and work we see in birds,
when birds are communicating
semantic information
in their sounds, which is not
too often, but it happens,
versus effective communication,
sing because I'm trying
to attract the mate,
my courtship song or defend my territory,
it's the same brain circuits.
It's the same speech-like or song,
circuits are being used in different ways.
- A friend of mine, who's
also a therapist, said to me,
you know, it's possible to say,
I love you with intense hatred
than to say, I hate you with intense love.
- [Eric] Right.
- And reminding me that
it's possible to hear
both of those statements in either way.
So I guess it's not just
limited to song or poetry.
It also, there's something
about the intention
and the emotional context
in which something spoken
that it can heavily shape the way
that we interpret what we hear.
- That's right.
And I consider all of
that actually, meaning,
even though I defined it as,
people commonly do semantic
and effective communication.
Effective communication
to say, I hate you,
but meant love, right,
does have emotional
meaning to it, you know?
And so, you know, one's more
like an object kind of meaning
or an abstract kind of meaning.
There's several other points here
I think it's important for those
listening out there to hear
is that when I say also
this effective and semantic communication
being used by similar brain circuits,
it also matters, the side of the brain.
In birds and in humans,
there's left-right dominance
for learned communication,
learned sound communication.
So the left in us humans is
more dominant for speech,
but the right has a
more balance for singing
or processing musical sounds
as opposed to processing speech.
Both get used for both reasons.
And so when people say your right brain
is your artistic brain
and your left brain is
your thinking brain,
this is what they're referring to.
And so that's another distinction.
A second thing that's useful to know
is that all vocal learning species
use their learned sounds
for this emotional
effective kind of communication,
but only a few of them like humans
and some parrots and dolphins
use it for the semantic
kind of communication,
we're calling speech.
And that has led a number
of people to hypothesize
that the evolution of
spoken language, of speech,
evolved first for singing,
for this more like emotional
kind of mate attraction
like the Jennifer Lopez,
the Ricky Martin kind
of songs and so forth.
And then later on,
it became used for abstract communication
like we're doing now.
- Oh, interesting.
Well, that's a perfect segue for me
to be able to ask you
about your background
and motor control, not only
of the hands but of the body.
So you have a number of important
distinctions to your name,
but one of them is that you were a member
of the Alvin Ailey Dance School,
School of Dance.
- That's right.
That's right, hmm hmm.
- So you're an accomplished
and quite able dancer, right?
Tell us a little bit about your background
in the world of dance
and how it informs your
interest in neuroscience,
[clears throat], excuse me,
and perhaps even how it relates
specifically to your work
on speech and language.
- Yes, well, it's interesting.
And then this kind of history
even goes before my time.
So in my family, my
mother and father's side,
they both went to the High
School of Music and Art
here in New York City.
And particularly, in my mother's family,
going back multiple
generations, they were singers.
And I even did my family genealogy
and found out not only, you know,
we have some relationships
to some well-known singers,
distant relationships
like Thelonious Monk,
but going back to the plantations
in North Carolina and so forth,
my ancestors were singers in the church
for the, you know, the towns and so forth.
And this somehow got passed on
multiple generations to my family.
And I thought I was going to grow up
and be a famous singer, right.
And me and my brothers and sister
formed a band when we
were kids and so forth.
But it turned out that I didn't inherit
the singing talents of some
of my other family members,
even though, you know,
I was, you know, okay.
You know, but not like my brother,
or not like my mother or my
aunts and my cousin Pura Fe',
who's now a talented
Native American singer.
And so,
that then influenced
me to do other things.
And I started, you know,
competing in dance contests,
you know, actually this is around the time
of Saturday Night Fever
and I was as a teenager.
And I started winning dance contests.
And I thought, oh, I can dance.
And I auditioned for the High
School of Performing Arts.
And I got in, here in New York City,
and got into ballet
dance and got in, right.
And thought, if I learned ballet,
I can learn everything else.
It I that idea, if you
learn something classical,
it can teach for everything else.
And I was, yeah, at
Alvin Ailey Dance School,
Joffrey Ballet Dance School.
And at the end of my senior concert,
I had this opportunity to audition
for the Alvin Ailey Dance Company.
And I had an opportunity to go to college.
And I also fell in love
with another passion
that my father had, which was science.
And so I liked science in high school.
And I found an overlap also
between the arts and sciences,
you know, both required
creativity, hard work, discipline,
you know, new discovery,
both weren't boring to me.
And the one decision I made
at that senior dance concert
was, you know, when talking
to the Alvin Ailey recruiter
and thinking about it,
I have to make a decision.
And I thought something
my mother taught me
because she was growing up in
the 1960s cultural revolution,
"Do something that has a
positive impact on society."
And I thought that I could do that better
as a dancer than a scientist.
So now jump, I get into
college, undergraduate school,
I major in molecular
biology and mathematics.
I decide I want to be a biologist,
got into graduate school,
wanted to study the brain at, you know,
at the Rockefeller University.
So I went from Hunter College
to Rockefeller University.
And so now I got to the brain
and why did I choose the brain
is because it controls dancing. [laughs]
But there wasn't anybody studying dancing.
And I wanted study the brain,
something that it does
that's really interesting and complex.
And I thought, ah,
language is what it does.
You couldn't study that in mice.
You couldn't study in non-human primates.
But these birds do this wonderful thing
that Fernando Nottebohm was
studying at Rockefeller.
And so that's what got me into the birds.
And then jumping now, 15 years later,
you know, yeah, that's right.
Even after I'm into now having my own lab,
studying vocal learning in these birds
as a model for language and humans,
it turns out that, you know,
Ani Patel and, you know, others,
have discovered that only
vocal learning species
can learn how to dance.
- Is that right?
- That's right, yes.
- So I've seen these just scrolling
through the files here in my mind.
I think about, every once
in a while someone will,
I love parrots.
- Yes.
- So every once in a while,
someone will send me one
of these little Instagram
or Twitter videos of a parrot
doing what looks to me like dance,
typically it's a cockatoo.
- That's right.
- Right.
- Even foot stomping to the sound and-
- Famous one called Snowball out there,
but there are many Snowballs
out there. [laughs]
- All the dancing birds
are named Snowball?
That's an interesting tactic.
So only animals with language dance?
- Yeah, vocal learning in particular,
the ability to imitate sounds, yes.
- Incredible.
- Yes.
And this now is bringing
my life full circle, right.
And so when that was discovered in 2009,
at that same time in my lab at Duke,
we had discovered that vocal
learning brain pathways
in songbirds, as well as in humans
and in parrots, right, like Snowball,
are embedded within circuits
that control learning how to move.
And that led us to a theory
called the Brain Pathway
or Motor Theory of Vocal Learning Origin
where the brain pathways for
vocal learning and speech
evolved by a whole duplication
of the surrounding motor circuits
involving learning how to move.
Now, how does that explain dance, right?
Well, when Snowball, the
cockatoos, are dancing,
they're using the brain regions
around their speech-like circuits
to do this dancing behavior.
And so what's going on there?
What we hypothesize and now like to test
is that when this,
when speech evolved in humans
and the equivalent behavior
and parrots and songbirds,
it required a very tight integration
in the brain regions that can hear sound
with the brain regions
that control your muscles
from moving your larynx
and tongue and so forth
for producing sound.
And that tight auditory motor integration,
we argue, then contaminated
the surrounding brain regions.
And that contamination of
the surrounding brain regions
now allows us humans, in
particular, and parrots.
to coordinate our muscle
movements of the rest of the body
with sound in the same way
we do for speech sounds.
- [Andrew] Well.
- So we're speaking with
our bodies when we dance.
- Incredible.
And I have to say that
as poor as I am at speaking
multiple languages,
I'm even worse at dancing, so.
- But I guarantee you're
better than a monkey.
- But not Snowball, the cockatoo?
- No, maybe not Snowball.
On YouTube, we have a video
where there's some scientists
dancing with Snowball
and you'll see Snowballs doing better
than some of the scientists.
- Okay, well, as long as I'm not the worst
of all scientists dancing.
- I don't think so.
- There's always a neuroplasticity.
May it save me someday.
You said something incredible
that I completely believe
even though I have minimum to,
let's just say minimum dancing ability.
Okay, I can get by at a party or wedding
without complete embarrassment,
but I don't have any structured training.
So the body clearly can
communicate with movement.
As a trained dancer and
knowing other trained dancers,
I always think of dance
and bodily movement
and communication through bodily movement
as a form of wordlessness,
like a state of wordlessness.
In fact, the few times when I think
that maybe I'm actually
dancing modestly well
for the context that I'm in,
or I see other people dancing
and they seem to just be
very much in the movement,
it's almost like a state of non-language,
non-spoken language.
- Hmm hmm.
- And yet what you're telling me is
that there's a direct bridge at some level
between the movement of
the body and language.
So is there a language of the body
that is distinct from
the language of speech?
And if so, or if not, how do
those map onto one another?
What does that Venn diagram look like?
- Yeah, yeah.
So, let me define first
dance in this context
of vocal learning species.
This is the kind of dancing
that we are specialized in doing
and the vocal learning species
are specialized in doing
is synchronizing body movements of muscles
to the rhythmic beats of music.
And for some reason, we like doing that.
We like synchronizing to sound
and doing it together
as a group of people.
And that kind of communication
amongst ourselves
is more like the effective
kind of communication
I mentioned earlier,
unlike the semantic kind.
So we, humans, are using our voices more
for the semantic, abstract communication,
but we're using learned dance
for the effective emotional
bonding kind of communication.
It doesn't mean we can't
communicate semantic information
in dance, and we do it,
but it's not as popular.
You know, like a ballet that,
you know, in the Nutcracker,
it is popular, you know,
where they are communicating,
you know, the Arabian guy comes out,
which I was the Arabian guy
in the ballet Nutcracker.
That's how I remember.
- Oh, yeah?
- Yeah, for the
Westchester Ballet Company,
when I was a teenager.
You know, we're trying
to communicate meaning
and our ballet dancing, it can go on
with a whole story and so forth.
But people don't interpret
that as clearly as speech.
You know, they're seeing the ballet
with semantic communication,
with a lot of emotional content,
whereas you go out to a club, you know,
yeah, you're not communicating,
okay, how you're feeling today?
Tell me about your day and so forth.
You're trying to synchronize
with other people
in an effective way.
And I think that's because,
the dance brain circuit
inherited the more ancient
part of the speech circuit,
which was for singing.
- I always had the feeling
that with certain forms of
music, in particular opera,
but any kind of music where
there's some long notes sung
that at some level,
there was a literal resonance created
between the singer and the listener.
Or I think of like the
deep voice of a Johnny Cash
or where at some level,
you can almost feel the
voice in your own body.
And in theory, that could
be the vibration of the
or the firing of the phrenic nerve
controlling the diaphragm for all I know.
Is there any evidence that
there's a coordination
between performer and audience
at the level of mind and body?
- I'm going to say, possibly, yes.
And the reason why is
because I just came back from a conference
on the neurobiology of dance-
- Clearly, I'm going
to the wrong meetings.
- Yeah, a colleague invited me.
- You know, vision science
sounds be so boring.
- Yes, well, one of my colleagues,
Tecumseh Fitch and Jonathan Fritz,
they organized, well, a particular section
on this conference in Virginia.
And this is the first
time I was in the room
with so many neuroscientists
studying the neurobiology of dance.
It's a new field now,
in the last five years.
And there was one lab
where they were putting EEG
electrodes on the dancers,
on two different dancers
partnering with each other,
as well as the audience,
you know, seeing the dance
and some, you know, argued,
okay, if you're listening
to the music as well,
how are you responding
'cause you're asking
a question about music
and I'm giving you an answer about dance.
And what they found is
that, you know, the dancers,
when they resonated with
each other during the dance,
or the audience listening to
the dancers and the music,
there's some resonance going on there
that they've score as higher resonance.
Their brain activity with
these wireless EEG signals
are showing something different.
And so that's why I say possibly, yes.
It needs more rigorous study
and you know, this is
some stuff they publish,
but it's not prime time yet,
but they're trying to figure this out.
- Love it.
So at least if I can't dance well,
maybe I can hear and feel
what it is to dance in a certain way.
- Yes, that's right.
And this will be, some
people will think that they,
even songs that they hear
and they can almost sing to
themselves in their own head
and they know what they
want it to sound like.
And you know when it really sounds good,
what it sounds like,
but they can't get their voice to do it.
- I'm raising, for those listening,
I'm raising my hand.
No musical ability.
Others in my household have
tremendous musical ability
with instruments and
with voice, but not me.
- Yeah, well, and so this
is one of my selfish goals
of trying to find the genetics
of why can some people who
sing really well and some not.
Is there some genetic
predisposition to that?
And then can I modify my own muscles
of brain circuits to sing better?
- You're still after the sing.
I guess this is what happens
when siblings vary in proficiency
is that competitiveness amongst brothers
and sisters never goes away.
- I've been trying to be
as good as my brother,
Mark and Victor, you
know, for my entire life.
- Well, watch out, Mark and Victor,
he's coming for you with
neuroscience to back him.
Earlier, you said that you
discovered that you could dance.
That caught my ear.
It sounds like you
didn't actually have to,
I'm not suggesting you
didn't work hard at it.
But at the moment where you discovered it,
it just sort of was a skill that you had,
that up until that point,
you didn't target a life
in the world of dance,
but the fact that you quote, unquote,
"discovered that you
could dance really well"
and then went to this
incredible school of dance
and did well,
tells me that perhaps there is an ability
that was built up in childhood
and or that perhaps we do all have
different genetic leanings
for different motor functions.
- Yeah, well, for me, there could be,
both explanations could be possible.
For the first, yeah,
I grew up in a family,
listening to Motown songs,
you know, dancing, you know,
at parties and so forth,
family parties and, you know,
an African American family, basically.
And so I grew up dancing
from a young child,
but this discovery, you know,
maybe dancing even moreso,
in terms of a talent,
it could, the genetic component,
if it really exists, I don't know.
You know, with my 23andMe
results, you know,
it says I have the genetic substitutions
that are associated with, you know,
high intensity athletes
and fast twitch muscles.
And who knows.
Maybe that could have something to do with
me being able to synchronize my body
to rhythmic sounds, maybe,
maybe, better than some others.
It turns out that my genetics also show
that I have a genetic substitute
that makes it hard for
me to sing on pitch.
And so that does correlate
with my, you know,
even though I can sing on this pitch,
especially if I hear a piano or, you know,
kind of playing it, but,
you know, maybe that's
why my siblings, you know,
who didn't have that
genetic predisposition
in his 23andMe results, you know,
it could go along with the
genetic component, as well.
- I'm imagining family
gatherings with 23andMe data
and intense arguments about it,
innate and learned ability.
- Yes.
- Fun.
Love to be an attendant.
I'm not inviting myself to
your Thanksgiving dinner
by the way, but I suppose I am.
- You're welcome to.
- Thank you.
I'll bring my 23andMe data.
I'd love to chat a moment
about facial expression
because that's a form
of motor pattern that,
you know, I think for
most people out there
just think about smiling and frowning,
but there are, of course,
you know, thousands,
if not millions of micro expressions
and things of that sort,
many of which are subconscious.
And we are all familiar with the fact that
when what somebody says
doesn't match some specific feature
of their facial expression
that it can call, you know,
that mismatch can cue our attention,
especially among people that
know each other very well.
Like somebody will say,
well, you said that,
but your right eye
twitched to the, you know,
a little bit in a way that tells me
that you didn't really mean that,
these kinds of things.
Or when, in the opposite example,
when the emotionality and
the content of our speech
is matched to a facial expression,
there's something that's
just so wonderful about that,
because it seems like
everything's aligned.
- [Erich] Yeah.
- So how does the motor circuitry
that controls facial expression
map onto the brain circuits
that control language,
speech, and even bodily
and hand movements?
- Yeah, and you ask a great question
because we both know some colleagues
like Winrich Freiwald at
Rockefeller University
who study facial expression
and the neurology behind it.
And now we both share some
students that we're co-mentoring.
And talk about this same
question that you brought up.
And what I'm learning a lot
is that non-human primates
have a lot of diversity
in their facial expression
like we humans do.
And what we know about the neurobiology
of brain regions controlling
those muscles of the face
is that these non-human primates
and some other species that don't learn
how to imitate vocalizations,
they have strong connections
from the cortical regions
to the motor neurons that
control facial expressions,
but absent connections or weak connections
to the motor neurons
that control the voice.
So I think our diverse facial expression,
even though it's more diverse
in these non-human primates,
there was already a preexisting
diversity of communication,
whether it's intentional or unconscious
through facial expression
in our ancestors.
And on top of that, we
humans now add the voice
along with those facial expressions.
- I see.
And in terms of language
learning when we're kids,
I mean, children, fortunately are not told
to fake their expressions
or to smile when they say I'm happy.
So at some point, everybody
learns, for better or for worse,
how to untangle these different
components of hand movement,
body posture, speech,
and facial expression.
- [Erich] Yes.
- But in their best form, I would say,
assuming that the best form is always,
I guess there are
instances where, you know,
for safety reasons, one might need
to fain some of these aspects of language.
But in most cases, when those are aligned,
it seems like that could reflect that
all the different circuitries
are operating in parallel,
but that the ability to misalign these
is also a powerful
aspect to our maturation.
I can think of theater, for instance,
where deliberate disentangling
of these areas is important.
But also we know when an actor,
when it feels real.
- Yep.
- And when it looks like,
when bad acting is oftentimes
when the facial expression or body posture
just doesn't quite match
what we're hearing.
- [Erich] Yeah.
- So are these skills that people,
that learn and acquire according
to adaptability and profession?
Or do you think that all
children and all adults
eventually learn how to couple
and uncouple these circuits a little bit?
- Yeah, I think it's this similar argument
I mentioned earlier about
the innate and learned
for the vocalizations.
And by the way, when I say,
we humans have facial expressions
associated with our vocalizations
in a different way than
primates, non-human primates,
it's the learned vocalizations
I'm talking about.
So there is a common view out there
that facial expressions
in non-human species
like nonhuman primates,
or you can have them in birds, too,
are innate, all right.
And so they're reflexive and controlled.
I don't believe that.
I think there's some
learned component to it.
And I think we have more
learning component to it as well,
but we also have an innate component.
And so if you try to put
your hands behind your back
and hold your fist, or even just not,
and try to speak and try to communicate,
it's actually harder to do.
You have to force yourself
or put it by your side.
This comes naturally.
Facial expressions comes naturally
because there's an innate component.
And yes, you have to learn
how to dissociate the two,
communicate something
angry with your hands
or with your face,
but, you know, politely with your voice.
It's very hard to separate those two,
because there is that innate component
that brings them together.
So it's like an email, too.
You're emailing and someone
says something by email,
someone can interpret
that angrily or gently,
and it becomes ambiguous.
The facial expressions
get rid of that ambiguity.
- So glad you brought that up
because my next question was,
and is about written language.
The first question I'll
ask is when you write,
either type or write things out by hand,
do you hear the content
of what you want to write
in your head?
Just, you personally.
- Yes, I do.
Yeah, and I know that I do,
because I was trying to figure
out a debate about this issue
and trying to resolve the debate
with my own self experimentation on me.
- I asked that because,
a quite well-known colleague of ours,
Karl Deisseroth at Stanford,
who's been on this podcast, you know,
his optogenetics fame and
psychiatry fame, et cetera.
- Yeah, I know him.
- Yeah, he sends his regards.
- Okay. [laughs]
- Told me that his practice for writing
and for thinking involves
a quite painful process
of forcing himself to sit completely still
and think in complete sentences,
to force thinking in complete sentences.
And when he told me that,
I decided to try this exercise
and it's quite difficult.
First of all, it's difficult
for the reason that you mentioned,
which is that with many thoughts,
I want to look around
and I start to gesticulate
with my hands, right?
So there it is, again,
the connection between
language and hand movement,
even if one isn't speaking.
And the other part that's challenging is
I realize that while we
write in complete sentences,
most of the time, we'll talk
about how that's changing now.
- Right.
- In texting, et cetera.
That we don't often think
in complete sentences,
and specifically in simple
declarative sentences,
that a lot of our thoughts would be,
if they were written out onto a page
would look pretty much
like passive language
that a good copy editor or
a good editor would say,
ugh, like we need to cross this out,
make this simple and declarative.
So what I'm getting at here is
what is the process of going
from a thought to language,
to written word?
And I also wanted to touch
on handwritten versus typed,
but thought to language, to written word.
What's going on there?
What do we know about
the neural circuitry?
And I was going to ask, why is it so hard?
But now I want to ask why
is this even possible?
It seems like a very challenging
neural computational problem.
- Yeah, yeah.
And coming from the linguistic world,
and even just the regular
neurobiology world,
going back to something I said before
about a separate language
module in the brain.
You know, there was this
thought or hypothesis
that this language module
has all these complex algorithms to them.
And they're signaling
to the speech circuit,
how to produce the sounds,
the hand circuit, how to
write them or gesture,
the visual pathway on how to
interpret them from reading
and the auditory pathway for listening.
I don't think that's the case, all right.
And you know, that this thinking where
there's this internal speech going on.
What I think is going on is
to explain what you're asking is about,
that I'm going to take
it from the perspective,
reading something.
You read something on a paper.
The signal from the paper
goes through your eyes.
It goes to the back of your brain,
to your visual cortical
regions eventually.
And then you now got to
interpret that signal
in your visual pathway
of what you're reading.
How are you going to do
that in terms of speech?
That visual signal then
goes to your speech pathway
in the motor cortex in
front here, in Broca's area.
And you silently speak what you read
in your brain without moving your muscles.
And sometimes actually, if
you put electrodes, EEG,
EMG electrodes on your laryngeal muscles,
even on birds, you can do this,
you'll see activity there while reading
or trying to speak silently,
even though no sound's coming out.
And so your speech pathway
is now speaking what you're reading.
Now to finish it off,
that signal is sent to
your auditory pathways
so you can hear what you're
speaking in your own head.
- That's incredible.
- And this is why it's complicated
because you're using like
three different pathways,
the visual, the speaking motor one,
and the auditory to read.
Oh, and then you got to write, right?
Okay, here comes the fourth one.
Now the hand areas next
to your speech pathway
has got to take that auditory signal
or even the adjacent
motor signals for speaking
and translate it into a
visual signal on paper.
So, you're using at least
four brain circuits,
which includes the speech production
and the speech perception
pathways to write.
- Incredible.
And finally, explain to me why,
so I was weaned teaching undergraduates,
graduate students and medical students
and I've observed that when I'm teaching,
I have to stop speaking
if I'm going to write
something on the board.
I just have to stop all
speaking completely.
- [Erich] Right.
- It turns out this is
an advantage to catch
because it allows me to catch my voice.
It allows me to slow down a bit, you know,
breathe and inhale some oxygen and so on
because I tend to speak quickly
if I'm not writing something out.
So there's a break in
the circuitry for me,
or at least they are distinct enough
that I have to stop and
then write something out.
- Yes, that does imply
competing brain circuits
for your conscious attention.
- We have colleagues up at Columbia Med
who are known, at least in our circles,
for voice dictating their
papers, not writing them out,
but just speaking into a voice recorder.
I've written papers that way.
It doesn't feel quite as natural for me
as writing things out.
- Yeah.
- But not because I can
go quickly from thought
to language to typing.
I type reasonably fast.
I can touch type now.
I don't think I ever taught my,
I think I taught myself.
I never took a touch typing course.
But it just sort of happened.
Now, I think, my motor system
seems to know where the keys are
with enough accuracy, that it works.
This is remarkable to me
that any of us can do this.
But when it comes to writing,
what I've found is that
if my rate of thought
and my rate of writing are
aligned nicely, things go well.
However, if I'm thinking
much faster than I can write,
that's a problem.
And certainly, if I'm thinking more slowly
than I want to write,
that's also a problem.
And the solution for me
has been to write with a pen.
I'm in love with these.
And I have no relationship to the company,
at least not now, although
if they want to come,
you know, if they want to work with us,
I love these Pilot V5, V7's
because not necessarily because of the ink
or the feel, although I like that as well.
But because of the rate
that it allows me to write,
they write very well slowly,
and they write very well quickly.
And so I have this theory,
supported only by my own anecdata,
no peer reviewed study,
that writing by hand is
fundamentally different
than typing out information.
Is there any evidence that
this motor pathway for writing
is better or somehow different
than the motor pathway for typing?
- Yeah, that's interesting.
And I don't know of any studies.
I have my own personal experience as well,
but trying to put this into the context,
if I had to, you know,
design an experiment to test
the hypothesis here that,
you know, to explain
your experience and mine,
is that writing by hand,
I would argue, requires a
different set of less skills
with the fingers than typing.
So you have to coordinate
your fingers more
in opposite directions
and so forth with typing,
but also writing by hand
requires more arm movement.
And so therefore, I would argue that
the difficulty there could be
in the types of muscles
and the fine motor control
you need of those muscles
along with speaking in your
brain at the same time.
- So basically, I'm a course, I'm a brute.
So it makes sense that I would have,
a more primitive writing
device would work.
- That's right, yes.
But, let me answer this in terms
of my own personal experience, right.
What I find is I can write
something faster by hand
for a short period of
time, compared to typing.
And that is because I think
I run out of the energy
in my arm movements
faster than I run out of muscle energy
in my finger movements.
And I think it takes longer time
for us to write words with our fingers,
because, and in terms of the speech.
So I think your writing,
whether it's by hand or
typing and your speech,
they only will align very well
if you can type as fast as you can speak
or write as fast as you
can speak in your head.
- I love it.
So what you've done, if
I understand correctly,
is created a bridge between
thought and writing,
and that bridge is speech.
- That bridge is speech, that's right.
That's right.
When you're writing something out,
you're speaking it to yourself.
And if you're speaking
faster than you can type,
you've got a problem.
- Interesting.
I do a number of podcast episodes
that are not with guests,
but solo episodes.
And as listeners know,
these are very long episodes,
often two or more hours.
And we joke around the podcast studio
that I will get locked
into a mode of speech
where some of it is more
collaborative and anecdotal
and then I'll punch out
simple declarative sentences.
I find it very hard to switch
from one module to the next.
The thing that I have done
in order to make that
transition more fluid
and prep for those podcast episodes
is actually to read the lyrics of songs
and to sing them in my head
as a way of warming up my vocal chords.
But luckily for those
around me, when I do that,
I'm not actually singing out loud.
And so this, what you're telling me
supports this idea that even
when we are imagining singing
or writing in our mind,
we are exercising our vocal chords.
- You're actually getting
little low potentials
of electrical currents
reaching your muscles there,
which also means you're exercising
your speech brain circuits too,
without actually, you know,
going with the full-blown
activity in the muscles.
- Incredible.
- Yeah.
And this idea of singing
helps you as well.
Even with Parkinson's
patients and so forth,
when they want to say something,
singing or listening to
music helps them move better.
And the idea there is that the
brain circuits for singing,
or let's say the function of
the brain circuits for speech
being used for singing first
is the more ancestral trait.
And that's why it's easier
to do things with singing
sometimes than it is with speaking.
- I love it.
Stutter is a particularly interesting case
and one that every once in a while,
I'll get questions about
this from our audience.
Stutter is complicated
in a number of ways,
but culturally, and my
understanding from these emails
that I receive is that
stutter can often cause
people to hide and speak less
because it can be embarrassing.
And we are often not patient with stutter.
We also have the assumption
that if somebody's stuttering,
that they're thinking is slow,
but it turns out there are many examples,
historically of people
who could not speak well,
but who were brilliant thinkers.
I don't know how well they could write,
but they found other
modes of communication.
I realize that you're not a
speech pathologist or therapist,
but what is the current neurobiological
understanding of stutter
and, or what's being developed
in terms of treatments for stutter?
- Yeah, so we actually accidentally
came across stuttering in songbirds.
And we've published several papers on this
to try to figure out the
neurobiological basis.
The first study we had was a brain area
called the basal ganglio,
or the striatum part of the basal ganglia
involved in coordinating movements,
learning how to make movements,
when it was damaged in a
speech-like pathway in these birds,
what we found is that
they started to stutter
as the brain region recovered.
And unlike humans,
they actually recovered
after three or four months.
And why is that the case?
Because bird brains
undergoes new neurogenesis
in a way that human or
mammal brains don't.
And it was the new neurons
that were coming in
into the circuit, but not quite, you know,
with the right proper activity
was resulting in this
stuttering, in these birds.
And after it was repaired,
not exactly the old song
came back after the repair,
but still it recovered a lot better.
And it's now known,
they call this neurogenic
stuttering in humans,
damage to the basal ganglia
or some type of disruption
to the basal ganglia at a young age,
also causes stuttering in humans.
And even those who are
born with stuttering,
it's often the basal
ganglia that's disrupted
than some other brain circuit
and we think the speech
part of the basal ganglia.
- Can adults who maintain
a stutter from childhood
repair that stutter?
- They can repair it with therapy,
with learning how to speak slower,
learning how to tap out a rhythm.
And yeah, I'm not a speech pathologist,
but I started reading this literature
and talking to others, that you know,
colleagues who actually study stuttering.
So yes, there are ways to
overcome the stuttering
through, you know, behavioral therapy.
And I think all of the tools out there
have something to do with
sensory motor integration,
controlling what you
hear with what you output
in a thoughtful controlled way
helps reduce the stuttering.
- There are a couple
examples from real life
that I want to touch on,
and one is somewhat facetious,
but now I realize, is a
serious neurobiological issue,
serious meaning I think interesting.
Which is that every once in a while,
I will have a conversation with somebody
who says the last word of
the sentence along with me.
And it seems annoying in some instances,
but I'm guessing this
is just a breakthrough
of the motor pattern
that they're hearing what
I'm saying very well.
So I'm going to interpret this kindly
and think they're hearing what I'm saying.
They're literally hearing it in their mind
and they're getting that
low-level electrical activity
to their throat.
And they're just joining me
in the enunciation of what I'm saying,
probably without realizing it.
Can we assume that that might be the case?
- Well, I wouldn't be
surprised so that, you know,
the motor theory of speech perception
where this idea originally came,
what you hear is going
through your speech circuit
and then also activating
those muscles slightly.
So yes, so one might argue,
okay, is that speech
circuit now interpreting
what that person is speaking?
Now, you're listening to me
and is going to finish it off
because it's already
going through their brain
and they can predict it?
That would be one theory.
And I don't think the
verdict out there is known,
but that's one.
The other is synchronizing
turn-taking in the conversation
where you're acknowledging
that we understand each other
by finishing off what I say.
And it's almost like a
social bonding kind of thing.
The other could be,
I want the person to shut up
so I can speak as well and take that turn.
And each pair of people have a
rhythm to their conversation.
And if you have somebody
who's over talkative
versus under talkative of vice versa,
that rhythm can be lost
in them finishing ideas
and going back and forth.
But I think having something
to do with turn-taking,
as well, makes a lot of sense.
- I have a colleague at Stanford who says
that interruption is a sign of interest.
[Erich laughs]
I'm not sure that everyone agrees.
I think it's highly contextual.
- [Erich] Yes.
- But there is this form of a verbal nod
of saying, hmm hmm or things of that sort.
And they're many of these.
And I'm often told by
my audience, you know,
that I interrupt my guests
and things of that sort.
Oftentimes, I'll just get
caught in the natural flow
of the conversation, but.
- Right.
Well, I think we've had
pretty good turn-taking here,
I hope.
- So far so good.
- I feel that way.
- I'm glad you feel that way,
because especially in the
context of a discussion
about language.
- Yes.
- It seems important.
Texting is a very, very
interesting evolution of language
because what you've told us
is that we have a thought,
it's translated into language.
It might not be complete sentences,
but texting, I have to
imagine this is the first time
in human evolution where
we've written with our thumbs.
So I don't know,
it seems more primitive to
me than typing with fingers
or writing with hands, but hey,
who am I to judge the
evolution of our species
in one direction or the other?
But the shorthand grammatically,
often grammatically deficient
incomplete sentence form
of texting is an incredible thing to see.
Early in relationships,
romantic relationships,
people will often evaluate the others text
and their ability to use proper grammar
and spelling, et cetera.
This often quickly degrades.
And there's an acceptance
that we're just trying to
communicate through shorthand,
almost military like shorthand,
but with internally
consistent between people,
but there's no general
consensus of what things mean,
but, you know, WTFs and like,
and OMGs and all sorts of things.
- [Erich] Right.
- I wonder sometimes whether or not
we are getting less proficient at speech
because we are not
required to write and think
in complete sentences.
- Hmm hmm.
- I'm not being judgemental here.
I see this in my colleagues.
I see this in myself.
This is not a judgment of
the younger generation.
I also know that slang
has existed for decades,
if not hundreds of years.
But I also know that I
don't speak the same way
that I did when I was a teenager,
because I've suppressed
a lot of that slang,
not because it's
inappropriate or offensive,
although some of it was, frankly,
but because it's out of context.
So what do you think's
happening to language?
Are we getting better at
speaking, worse at speaking?
And what do you think the role of things
like texting and tweeting
and shorthand communication, hashtagging,
what's that doing to the
way that our brains work?
- Yeah, I think that,
well, one, in terms of, you know,
measuring your level of
sophistication and intelligence
when you say OMG, right.
I think that also could
be a cultural thing
that, ah, you belong
to the next generation.
If you're an, you know,
or you're being cool,
if you're an older person, you know,
using OMG and other
things that the, you know,
younger generation would use.
But if I really think about it clearly,
texting actually has allowed
for more rapid communication
amongst people.
I think, without the invention
of the phone before then,
or, you know, texting back and forth,
you had to wait days
for a letter to show up.
You couldn't call somebody on the phone
and talk as well, you know?
And so this rapid communication
in terms of the rapid communication
of writing in this case.
So I think actually,
it's more like a use it or lose it
kind of a thing with the brain.
The more you use a particular
brain region or circuit,
the more enhanced.
It's like a muscle.
The more you exercise it,
the more healthier it is,
the bigger it becomes and
the more space it takes
and the more you lose something else.
So I think texting is not decreasing
the speech prowess,
or the intellectual prowess of speech.
It's converting it and using
it a lot in a different way,
in a way that may not be
as rich in regular writing,
because you can only
communicate so much nuance
in short-term writing,
but whatever is being done,
you got people texting hours and hours
and hours on the phone.
So whatever, your thumb circuit
is going to get pretty big,
actually. [laughs]
- I do wonder whether, you know,
many people have lost
their jobs based on tweets.
- [Erich] Hmm hmm.
- The short latency
between thought and action
and distribution of one's thoughts
is incredible.
- Yes.
- And I'm not just talking about people
who apparently would have poor
prefrontal top-down control.
This is geek speak by the way,
for people that lack impulse control.
But high-level academics,
I'm not going to point fingers at anyone.
But examples of where you
see these tweets and you go,
what were they thinking?
- Yep.
- So presumably, there's
an optimal strategy
between the thought speech motor pathway,
especially when the motor
pathway engages communication
with hundreds of thousands of people
and retweets in particular
and the cut and paste function
and the screenshot function
are often the reason
why speech propagates.
- [Erich] Yep.
- So to me, it's a little eerie that,
just that the neural circuitry can do this
and that we are catching
up a little bit more slowly
to the technology,
and you've got these
casualties of that mismatch.
- I think that's a good
adjective used, the casualties,
you know, of what's going on,
because yes, it is the case with texting,
what you're really losing there
is less so the ability to write,
but more the ability to
interpret what is being written.
And you can over or under interpret
something that somebody means.
On the flip side of that, you know,
if somebody's writing
something very quick,
they could be writing instinctually,
more instinctually, their true meaning,
and they don't have time to modify
and color code what they're trying to say.
And that's what they really feel
and as opposed to saying
it in a more nuanced way.
So I think both sides of
that casualty are present.
And that's a downturn, you know,
unintended negative
consequence of short-term,
I mean, short-word communications.
- Yeah, I agree that this whole phenomenon
could be netting people that normally
would only say these things out loud
once inside the door of their own home.
- Right.
- Or not at all.
- [Erich] Right.
- It's an interesting time that we're in.
These are these speech and
language and motor patterns.
- So part of the human
evolution for language,
I think this is all part of our evolution.
- That's right.
- Yeah.
- So for those of you
thinking terrible thoughts,
please put them in the
world and be a casualty.
And for those of you that are not,
please be very careful with how proficient
your thought to language
to motor action goes.
- [Erich] Yes. [laughs]
- Maybe the technology companies
should install some buffers,
some AI-based buffers.
- Right, that's taking some EEG signals
from your brain while
you're texting to say,
okay, this is not a
great thought, slow down.
- Right, or this doesn't
reflect your best state.
That brings me to
what was going to be the
next question anyway,
which is we are quickly
moving toward a time
where there will be an
even faster transition
from thought to speech, to motor output,
and maybe won't require motor output.
What I'm referring to here
is some of the incredible
work of our colleagues,
Eddie Chang at UCSF and others
who are taking paralyzed human beings
and learning to translate
the electrical signals
of neurons in various areas,
including speech and language areas,
to computer screens that type out
what these people are thinking.
In other words,
paralyzed people can put
their thoughts into writing.
That's a pretty extreme
and wonderful example
of recovery of function.
- Hmm hmm.
- That is sure to continue to evolve.
But I think we are headed toward a time,
not too long from now
where my thoughts can be
translated into words on a page
if I allow that to happen.
- Yeah so, and Eddie Chang's work,
which I admire quite a
bit and cite in my papers,
I think he's really one of
those at the leading edge
of trying to understand within humans,
the neurobiology of speech.
And he may not say it
directly, but you know,
I talked to him about this.
It supports this idea
that the speech circuit
and the separate language module,
I don't really think that
there's a separation there.
So with that knowledge,
yes, and putting
electrodes into human brain
and then translating
those electrical signals
to speech currents.
Yeah, we can start to tell
what is that person thinking?
Why, because we often
think in terms of speech.
And without saying words.
And that's a scary thought.
And now imagine if you can now translate
those into a signal that
transmits something wirelessly
and someone from some
distant part of the planet
is hearing your speech
from a wireless signal
without you speaking.
So probably that won't be
done in an ethical way,
who knows, you know?
But I mean, the ethics
of doing that probably,
you know, might not happen, but who knows?
We have these songbirds, you know.
If we apply the same technique to them,
we can start to hear what they're singing
in their dreams or whatever,
even though they don't produce sound
so we can find out by testing on them.
- It's coming.
- Yes.
- One way or another, it's coming.
For those listening who are interested
in getting better at speaking
and understanding languages,
are there any tools that you recommend?
And here again,
I realize you're not a speech therapist,
but here I'm not thinking about
ameliorating any kind
of speech deficiency.
I'm thinking, for instance,
do you recommend that people read
different types of writing?
Would you recommend that
people learn how to dance
in order to become better at
expressing themselves verbally?
You know, and feel free to
have some degrees of freedom
in this answer.
These are obviously not
peer-reviewed studies
that we're referring to,
although there may be,
but I'm struck by the number of things
that you do exceedingly well,
and I can't help but ask,
well, the singing, which I realize it may,
your brother didn't pay me to say this,
may not be quite as good
as your brothers yet,
but is getting, you'll surpass him,
I'm guessing at some point.
♪ Getting there ♪
- Getting there.
[both laughing]
Exactly, there you go.
You know, should kids learn how to dance
and read hard books and simple books?
What do you recommend?
Should adults learn how to do that?
Everyone wants to know how
to keep their brain working
better, so to speak.
But also I think people want
to be able to speak well
and people want to be
able to understand well.
- Yeah, so what I've
discovered personally, right,
is that, so when I switched
from pursuing a career in
science from a career in dance,
I thought one day I would stop dancing,
but I haven't because I
find it fulfilling for me,
you know, just as a life experience.
So ever since I started college,
you know, my late teens
and early twenties,
I kept dancing even till this day.
And there've been periods of time,
like during the pandemic
where I slowed down on
dancing and so forth.
And when you do that, you realize, okay,
there are parts of your body
where your muscle tone decreases
a little bit and somewhat,
or you could start to gain weight.
I somehow don't gain weight that easily.
And I think it's related to my dance,
if that's meaningful to your audience.
But what I found is, you know,
in science, we like to
think of a separation
between movement and action and cognition.
And there is a separation for you
between perception and production,
cognition being perception,
production being moving, right.
But if the speech pathways
is next to the movement pathways,
what I discover is by dancing,
it is helping me think.
It is helping keeping my brain fresh.
It's not just moving my muscles,
I'm moving or using the
circuitry in my brain
to control a whole big body.
You need a lot of brain tissue to do that.
And so I argue,
if you want to stay cognitively
intact into your old age,
you better be moving
and you better be doing it consistently,
whether it's dancing, walking, running,
and also practicing speech,
oratory speech and so forth or singing,
is controlling the brain circuits
that are moving your facial musculature.
And it's going to keep your
cognitive circuits also in tune.
And I'm convinced of that from
my own personal experience.
- Yeah, for me, long, slow runs
are a wonderful way to
kind of loosen the joints
for long podcasts,
especially the solo podcast,
which can take many hours to record.
And without those long slow runs,
at least the day before,
or even the morning of,
I don't think I could do
it, at least not as well.
- All right, well, you're
experiencing something similar.
So that's an N of two.
- Yeah, N of two.
I'm tempted to learn how to dance
because there are a lot of
reasons to learn how to dance.
- [Erich] Yes.
- And people can use their imagination.
I definitely want to get the opportunity
to talk about some of the newer work
that you're into right now
about genomes of animals.
As you perhaps can tell
from my quite authentic
facial expressions,
I adore the animal kingdom.
I just find it amazing.
And it's the reason I went
into neurobiology, in part.
So many animals, so many
different patterns of movement,
so many body plans, so
many specializations,
what is the value of learning the genomes
of all these animals?
You know, I can think of
conservation-based, you know,
schemes of trying to preserve
these precious critters,
but what are you doing with
the genomes of these animals?
What do you want to understand
about their brain circuits?
And how does this relate
to some of the discussion
we've have been having up until now?
- Yeah, I've gotten very
heavily involved in genomes,
you know, not just to
get at an individual gene
involved in the trade of
interest, like spoken language,
but I realize that, you know,
nature has done natural experiments for us
with all these species out
there with these various traits
and the one that I'm
studying, like vocal learning,
has evolved multiple times
among the animal kingdom,
even if it's rare, it's multiple times.
And the similar genetic changes
occurred in those species.
But to find out what those genetic changes
that are associated with
the trait of interests
and not some other trait
like flying in birds,
as opposed to singing,
you have to do what's
called comparative genomics,
even in the context of studying the brain.
And you need their genomes
to compare the genomes
and do like a GWA, a
genome-wide association study,
not just within a species like
humans, but across species.
And so you need good genomes to do that.
Plus, I've discovered I'm also interested
in evolution and origins.
How did these species
come about a similar trait
in last, you know, 300 million
years or 60 million years,
depending who you're talking about.
And you need a good
phylogenetic tree to do that,
and to get a good phylogenetic tree,
you also need their genomes.
And so, because of this,
I got involved in large scale consortiums
to produce genomes of
many different species,
including my vocal learners
and their closest
relatives that I'm fans of.
But I couldn't convince
the funding agencies
to gimme the money to do
that just for my own project.
But when you get a whole
bunch of people together
who want to study various traits,
you know, heart disease,
or loss and gain in flight and so forth,
suddenly we all need lots
of genomes to do this.
And so now that got me into a project
to lead something called the
Vertebrate Genomes Project
to eventually sequence all
70,000 species on the planet.
And Earth BioGenome Project,
all eukaryotic species,
all two million of them.
And to no longer be in a situation
where I wish I had this genome.
Now we have the genetic code
of all life on the planet,
create a database of all their traits
and find the genetic association
with everything out there
that makes a difference
from one species to another.
One more piece of the
equation to add to this story
is what I didn't realize
as a neuroscientist
were that these genomes
are not only incomplete,
but have lots of errors in them,
false gene duplications,
where mother and father chromosomes
were so different from each other,
that the genome algorithm,
assembly algorithms treated
them as two different genes
in this part of the chromosome.
So there are a lot of these
false duplicated genes
that people thought
were real, but were not
or missing parts of the genome
because the enzymes
used to sequence the DNA
couldn't get through
this regulatory region
that folded up on itself
and made it hard to sequence.
And so I ended up in these consortiums
pulling in the genome
sequencing companies,
developing the technology to work with us
to improve it further
and the computer science guys
who then take that data
and that technology,
and try to make the complete genomes
and make the algorithms better
to produce what we now just did recently
led by an effort by Adam Phillippy
is the first human
Telomere-to-Telomere Genome
with no errors, all complete,
no missing sequence.
And now we're trying to do the
same thing with vertebrates
and other species.
Actually, we improved
that before we got to the,
what we call telomere-to-telomere,
from one end of the chromosome to another.
And what we're discovering
is in this dark matter of the genome
that was missing before,
turns out to be some regulatory regions
that are specialized in
vocal learning species
and we think are involved in
developing speech circuits.
- Incredible.
Well, so much to learn.
And we're going to learn
from this information.
Early on in these genome
projects and connectome projects,
I confess I was a little bit cynical.
This would be about 10, 15 years ago.
I thought, okay, necessary,
but not sufficient for anything.
We need it, but it's not
clear what's going to happen,
but you just gave a very clear example
of what we stand to learn
from this kind of information.
And I know from the conservation side,
there's a huge interest in this
because even though we would prefer
to keep all these species
alive rather than clone them,
these sorts of projects
do offer the possibility
of potentially recreating
species that were lost.
- [Erich] Right.
- Due to our own ignorance or
missteps, or what have you.
- Yes, and along those lines,
because, you know, we
got involved in genomics,
some of the first species
that we start working on
are critically endangered species.
And I'm doing that not only for, you know,
perspectives to understand their brains
and the genes involved
in their brain function,
but I feel like it's a moral duty.
So the fact that now
I become more involved
in genome biology
and have helped develop these tools
for more complete genomes,
let's capture their genetic
code now, before they're gone.
And could we use that information
to resurrect the species
at some future time,
if not in my lifetime,
in some time in the future
and generations ahead of us.
And so, in anticipation of that,
we create a database,
we call the GenomeArk
and no pun intended like Noah's Ark,
meant to store the genetic code
as complete genome assemblies as possible
for all species on the planet
to be used for basic science,
but also some point in the future.
And because of that,
funding agencies or private foundations
that are interested in conservation
have been reaching out to
me now, a neuroscientist,
to help them out in producing
high quality genome data
of endangered species that they can use,
like Revive & Restore,
who want to resurrect the passenger pigeon
or Colossal, who wants to
resurrect the wooly mammoth.
And so we're producing
high quality genomes
for these groups, for the
conservation projects.
- What a terrific and
important initiative.
And I think for those listening today,
they now certainly understand the value
of deeply understanding
the brain structures
and genomes of different species.
Because I confess,
even though I knew a bit
of the songbird literature,
and I certainly understand
that humans have speech and language,
I had no idea that there
was so much convergence
of function, structure and genomes.
And to me, you know,
I feel a lot more like
an ape than I do a songbird.
- Right.
- And yet here we are
with the understanding
that there's a lot more similarity
between songbirds and humans
than I certainly ever thought before.
- Yeah, something very
close to home for us humans,
I can give you an example of
is evolution of skin color.
And skin color, we use it unfortunately,
for racism and so forth.
We use it also for good
things to let in more light
or let out less light depending
on the part of the planet,
you know, our population evolved in.
And most people think dark-skinned people
all evolved from the
same dark-skinned person
and light-skinned people all evolved
from the same light-skinned person,
but that's not the case.
Dark skin and light skin amongst humans
has evolved independently multiple times,
like in, you know, the
Pacific islands versus Africa.
And it's just depending on the angle
of light hitting the Earth
as to whether you need more
protection from the sun
or less protection,
that's also associated with
Vitamin D synthesis in the skin.
And so, and each time,
where darker or lighter
skin evolved independently,
it hit the same gene, you know,
the mela [finger snaps].
- Melanin.
- Melanin receptors.
That's right, yes, yeah.
Genes that are involved
in melanin in formation.
And so those genes evolve
some of the same mutations,
even in different species.
It's not just humans.
In equatorial regions, they
are darker-skinned animals
than going away from the equator.
- Oh, right, I think of Arctic foxes
and things of that sort.
- Yep, that's right.
That's right, polar bears, you know,
and so some of the same genes are used
in evolutionary perspective
to evolve in a similar way
within and across species.
- Incredible.
- Yeah.
And that's same thing
happening in the brain too.
Language is no exception.
- Well, I have to say,
as somebody who is a, you
know, career neuroscientist,
but as I mentioned several times now,
who also adores the animal kingdom,
but is also obsessed
with speech and language,
at a distance not as a
practitioner of music and dance,
this has been an incredible conversation
and opportunity for me to learn.
And I know I speak for a
tremendous number of people
and I just really want to say,
thank you for joining us today.
You are incredibly busy.
It's clear from your
description of your science
and your knowledge base,
that you are involved in
a huge number of things,
very busy, so thank
you for taking the time
to speak to all of us.
Thank you for the work that you're doing,
both on speech and language,
but also this important work on genomes
and conservation of endangered
species and far more.
And I have to say,
if you would agree to come back
and speak to us again sometime,
I'm certain that if we were
to sit down even six months
or a year from now, there's
going to be a lot more to come.
- Yeah, we have some things cooking
and thank you for inviting me here
to get the word out to the community
of what's going on in the science world.
- Well, we're honored and
very grateful to you, Erich.
Thank you.
- You're welcome.
- Thank you for joining
me today for my discussion
with Dr. Erich Jarvis.
If you'd like to learn more
about his laboratory's work,
you can go to Jarvis Lab,
spelled J-A-R-V-I-S lab,
all one word, jarvislab.net.
And there you can learn
about all the various studies
taking place in his laboratory,
as well as some of the
larger overarching themes
that are driving those studies,
including studies on human
genomics and animal genomics
that surely are going to lead
to the next stage discoveries
of how we learn and think about,
and indeed use language.
If you're learning from and
or enjoying this podcast,
please subscribe to our YouTube channel.
That's a simple zero
cost way to support us.
Please also subscribe to the
podcast on Spotify and Apple.
And on both Spotify and Apple,
you have the opportunity to leave us
up to a five star review.
If you have questions or
comments or suggestions
about topics you'd like us to cover,
or guests you'd like us to interview
on the Huberman Lab Podcast,
please put those in the
comment section on YouTube.
We do read all those comments
and we do take them to heart.
Please also check out the sponsors
mentioned at the beginning
of today's podcast.
And check out Momentous supplements,
our new partners in the supplement space.
And check out Athletic Greens.
That's the best way to
support this podcast.
If you're not already
following us on social media,
please do so.
We are hubermanlab on Twitter,
and we are also hubermanlab on Instagram.
In both places, I cover science
and science-related tools,
some of which overlap with the content
of the Huberman Lab Podcast,
but much of which is unique
from the content covered
on the Huberman Lab Podcast.
Again, that's hubermanlab on Instagram
and hubermanlab on Twitter.
Please also check out our Neural
Network monthly newsletter.
This is a newsletter that has
summaries of podcast episodes.
It also includes a lot
of actionable protocols.
It's very easy to sign
up for the newsletter.
You go to hubermanlab.com,
click on the menu,
go to newsletter.
You supply your email,
but we do not share
your email with anybody.
We have a very clear and
rigorous privacy policy,
which is we do not share
your email with anybody.
And the newsletter comes out once a month
and it is completely zero cost.
Again, just go to hubermanlab.com
and go to the Neural Network Newsletter.
I'd also like to point out
that the Huberman Lab
Podcast has a clips channel.
So these are brief clips anywhere
from three to 10 minutes,
that encompass single concepts
and actionable protocols
related to sleep, to focus,
interviews with various guests.
We talk about things like caffeine,
when to drink caffeine relative to sleep,
alcohol, when and how,
and if anyone should ingest
it relative to sleep,
dopamine, serotonin, mental
health, physical health,
and on and on, all the things
that relate to the topics
most of interest to you.
You can find that easily
by going to YouTube,
look for Huberman Lab
Clips in the search area,
and it will take you there, subscribe,
and we are constantly
updating those with new clips.
This is especially useful, I believe,
for people that have missed
some of the earlier episodes,
or you're still working
through the back catalog
of Huberman Lab Podcast,
which admittedly can be rather long.
And last, but certainly not least,
thank you for your interest in science.
[lively music]